what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch
Wednesday the penultimate episode
John how are you I am thrilled and
excited and Spooktacular sir how are you
I'm doing great doing great hoping this
is a good one with that in mind ladies
and gentlemen you know would help us out
with this video if you leave a like
please go ahead and leave that like we'd
love it if you would leave that like
secondly subscribe and click the
notification Bell get notified when a
reaction is over to the finale that'd be
very much appreciated as always foreign
exclusively over there several shows
reaction highlights and watch Longs
included I am done with this intro let's
move on
foreign
funerals I've been crashing them since I
was old enough to read the obituary
section
what's your favorite obituary mayor
Walker was murdered and I know the
Killer is here
and watching everything I do
started out of the soul I have all the
pieces of the jigsaw
I just need to slap them into place like
the rainbow in between yeah yeah well
placed all the pieces are assembled
[Music]
am I supposed to be mourning this mayor
because
you seem like a pretty awful guy
don't worry I'm gonna start crying any
second now
[Music]
oh this is definitely going to be the
Killer
God that coat I want that coat
[Music]
that's sweet still as sharp as ever my
pigtailed protege
oh a smile oh cool yes
let's go I'm sorry you said that he
would be He Said Fred armisen's playing
him yeah
I'm waiting for this just blew into town
this morning and was hit by a wave of
nostalgia I thought you didn't go to
Nevermore your dad got all the brains he
filled me in on what's been going on
Monsters murder Mayhem Mischief what fun
I'd be checking up on you
what kind of job the climate means I
need someone to lay low for a couple
days spit off yeah I want to side Series
where Fester's going around whacking
people cooking fools this place belongs
to a friend you've actually made a
friend
that poor kid will be going home in a
body bag
oh spoke too soon I like a hideout that
comes with snacks or practically
Eugene's children
that means do not eat them
what kind of a monster you're dealing
with
haven't been able to identify it
it's called a hide a hide a hide in 83
during my vacay at the Zurich Institute
for the criminally insane
so I got my first lobotomy but you know
lobotomies they're kind of like tattoos
you can't just get one
and even numbers are bad luck she had it
all
beauty brains and a penchant for neck
nice let's go did you just change on her
own no idea
I only saw her in group electroshock
therapy
tried Nathaniel Faulkner's diary okay
where is it night shades Library
we'll sneak into the night trades
library tonight
in the meantime lay low Fester you're
more perfect for this case
if you are discovered
I will disown you and collect other
reward money tied to your capture and
expect nothing less
and don't eat the bees
leave the bees alone
bees are endangered right now bees are
friends not food of course goody is
nowhere to be found when I need her
that can be just as annoying and
unreliable as the living you're annoying
and unreliable unit
speak of the devil
how's everything going Solitude suit
suits me with no annoying distractions
I'm almost finished with my novel
was I an annoying distraction you
definitely had some annoying habits that
distracted me when you text which is a
24 7 addiction well Elise is not a
migraine inducing typewriter hammering
into my head when you're not grinding
your canines you growl in your sleep as
opposed to late night cello solos
complain about them non-stop I dig that
over your obsession with all things
creepy and dead you could gas an entire
small village with the amount of perfume
you spreads
ouch Jesus fight fight hyoko and I are
so in sync that she's begging me to be
her new roomie permanently
don't let me hold you back you seem
slightly affected I could see a romance
between them that would be interesting
[Music]
did you know Jenna Ortega did not snap
with her left uh hand so she had to
spend three months learning does this
really
that's a very long time I know people
have trouble with it but God
you don't know who your real friends are
I've been on your side since day one I
literally saved your life
it's true you want honesty here it is
every time the monsters attacked you
have been right there starting with
Rowan at the Harvest Festival
someone else has been right there the
whole time you arrived at the meeting
house just minutes after the monster had
disappeared yet you say you didn't see
it
you're a mystery writer Wednesday you
know this is all too convenient even
Drew where it lived then when Eugene
went to investigate
you think I would hurt Eugene
if I Am The Monster
why haven't I killed you poke the hole
there because for some reason I cannot
fathom or indulge you seem to like me
what's the luck
a lot damn dude he's just making [ __ ] up
yeah you know there's a lot to like just
trying to protect your prize desired
girl
how long have you been lurking long
enough to feel the tension between you
two
hello thing
oh you can't still be mad about the
Kalamazoo job it wasn't my fault oh no
I'm finished enough
[Music]
let him go show me the diary
foreign
do I have time for a snooze or can you
crack this one quickly
thing doesn't need a stethoscope or a
Walkman
[Music]
a cinch
he's dormant to till Unleashed by a
traumatic event or unlock through
chemical inducement or hypnosis
this act caused aside to develop an
immediate bond with its Liberator who
the creature now sees its Master becomes
the Willing instrument of whatever and
Affairs agenda this new master might
propose interesting so he's Tyler's
being controlled that's right it's none
of it's his fault that means I'm not
looking for one killer but two exactly I
said there were toast dude
I just thought there were two hides I'm
right there with you Wednesday we'll
figure this out together Homie we all
finished the novel for you
Enid has requested a room with Yoko for
the rest of the school year you two
seemed as thick as thieves ultimately
thieves turn on each other no honor
among Thieves
part of the dorm experience is making
friends with people that you wouldn't
normally connect with and those
friendships often turn into lifelong
bonds I would rather buy a rope hahaha
well if that's your decision I'll submit
the forms to principal Weems I wonder if
they give these seats to Christina
Ritchie
yeah let's grab me some crazy like fan
theory that she's like she is still
Wednesday from altering yeah and sucked
through a vortex
Uncle Fester
Lobo has its perks you get to live by
your own rules do whatever you want just
look at me
oh Fest how did he get in there so
perfectly I know how long did that take
him yeah I know where that is
okay I can meet you there in like 20
minutes
okay bye who are you talking to whoa
how'd you do that it's none of your
goddamn business I know what you are
Xavier can you stay the hell away from
me
nah come on Wednesday did you place the
tracker
[Music]
Uncle Fester's got you covered
it's so old school yes
[Music]
you know me I like to travel incognito
it's the perfect color scheme this
episode feels very Adam's Family
[Music]
that's Xavier all right
[Music]
dang what God damn it Tyler you're
confusing the whole situation
nah nah don't lose don't lose weight
and she shall appear
I've been reading about hypnotherapy I
think it might be a good technique to
unlock my inner Wednesday
I applaud your new willingness to delve
deep into yourself yeah yeah
let's do some EMDR Wednesday
canbot has to be sages master
the hide delays dormant until Unleashed
by a traumatic event or unlock their
chemical inducement or hypnosis
[Music]
to figure out he was a hot and used
hypnotherapy to unlock him that would
explain their secret sessions
I think the kid behind the counter has
clocked me foreign
relax
[Laughter]
need a refill on this puppy too
Tyler this is my Uncle Fester so
Disturbed Heights
it's a better version of one of those
prank things
from back in the 80s that's it from that
night your father gave you explicit
instructions not to be near me
dad's not here and I want to break and
you came into the shop apparently a high
needs to be unlocked
get away from her
for the record Wednesday was trying to
keep her distance I was the one that sat
down with her all right
putting these up around town to bank
robbery suspect and he's a real creep
of course
about rescheduling our date
well I can't make off of Kim campus all
eyes are on me
you won't have to
I'll come to you 9pm Corrections [ __ ]
sounds romantic you want to go on
another date after all that [ __ ]
unless of course it has something to do
with the fact that she's figured out
what he is she knows that you're right
that's right your job is to guard that
diary while I'm gone
I'll be back as soon as I can
it's not a date
it's a quid pro quo for almost getting
him disemboweled a quid pro whoa
okay you can open your eyes now
oh wow what a date how romantic
[Music]
how do you feel about scary movies this
is like the best day ever oh she got a
smile going
oh oh no
oh
are they watching
legally blind
[Music]
there's definitely a suspect's bike all
right he couldn't get too far on foot so
you guys spread out
I'm gonna check down by the lake you
don't know Uncle Fester man
you can keep trying to push me away it's
not gonna work
who almost killed you I survived
beginner's luck I'm tougher than you
think
you want to see you're making a mistake
probably his mistake to make oh my God
he's gonna go for it never been this
tense during it oh it almost happened
oh Ugg I'm not gonna even ask what this
is but I never saw the two of you here
you got it make sure not to tell me
about it later damn Wednesday was not
pulling back on that kiss yeah she
turned into it
oh [ __ ] diary thing
[Music]
no
no what are we implying right now no
no no you gotta be kidding me they
better be able to bring him back no they
wouldn't get some of Fester's
electricity no he's got to be alive so
they wouldn't kill him off
[Music]
get him on the table
do a back alley operation on him
[Music]
come on
oh come on thing
oh no she's crying no no
[Music]
way they wouldn't I don't buy it are
they really come on It's gotta be a fake
out he's gone Wednesday
no he's not thing
if you can hear me
if you die I will kill you
please
maximum power Fester
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
yes yes
nice from behind the back cowards
promised that whoever did this to you
will suffer it won't be slow
long and excruciatingly painful yes is
because it should be break out the rack
that was cruel the sheriff won't be far
you need to go I'll lay low here tonight
keep an eye on the patient
I'll skedaddle in the morning
come back next season men are the next
family reunion
it'll always be my favorite Wednesday
sure to tell pugsy that
wow you guys we almost lost thing right
now it really had me going yeah
he wanted to determine if they were just
Mindless Killers or conscious of their
actions what was his conclusion
yes killed by a Hyde before he could
reach one ironic if you suspect someone
you need to tell me why well you've ever
done is go outside and obstruct me true
I am protecting our Livermore family
which also includes you in atoms if I
could protect everyone but you I would
Mary should be all right in the end
I'm roon for I don't I don't I don't
know what I'm rooting for come with me
I have information about Mayo Walker's
murder
okay
good to see you too let's go
he's off my dad's computer seems he was
trying to track down someone Laurel
Gates looks like he started right after
average day he must have recognized her
there according to the British police
report Laura was presumed drought but
nobody was ever recovered a likely story
The Gates mansion was purchased a year
ago by a 90 year old candy Eris she then
mysteriously died and gave all of her
belongings to her caregiver
Theresa Oklahoma it's an anagram for
Laurel Gates
the monster is called a hide it's been
doing Laurel spitting she controls it
you know who Laurel is
what's up I was right because John
guessed it first
you are correct
well done
I know you're Laurel Cates you've come
back to Jericho to seek your revenge and
so did mayor Walker which is why you had
to kill him
I mean who better decide in and out of
the hospital undetected than a
psychiatrist under the guise of visiting
another patient I hope you're writing a
recorder yeah please I honestly have no
idea what you're talking about there's
only one reason an overqualified
psychiatrist like yourself would settle
in the inconsequential Backwater that is
Jericho hey I don't have time to deal
with your delusional fantasies I have a
patient emergency who savior
do you know how violently unpredictable
a hide can be or would you plan to have
Xavier committed before you could turn
on YouTube Wednesday you need help more
help than I can give you Who you calling
Xavier
I'm going to recommend you stay in a
juvenile psychiatric facility for
observation oh please you and I both
know I'd be running that place in a week
[Laughter]
time's up Laurel
Checkmate I hope you were wearing a
recorder even though she did not confess
she did not incriminate herself but she
is suspicious as hell
principal Weems it's Valerie kimbot
Wednesday Adams just barged into my
office during our appointment
[Laughter]
was completely irrational
yep that's right irrational
oh the hides in there
damn is my theory about to be wrong
foreign
was wrong you [ __ ] that's definitely
Tyler though I gotta retire
who would be controlling the hide
is it him she's gone baby I have to come
back to dead oh damn well
you left that in my room
actually you left it in thing how long
have you been seeing kinbot you've been
spying on me right kung fu fight
work
your painting has been improving
I enjoy this one in particular
Fizz Ron's inhaler doing in your shed
are Eugene's glasses
whoa
are these stalker images you took of me
don't forget your latest edition
they're plants necklace no no somebody
planted that stuff
drop the knife down on your knees
damn you framed me I'm being set up I
should have let Rowan kill you
oh damn shadow of a doubt Wednesday
definitely Tyler
what episode left
a few days the place gets trashed and
thing almost dies
someone's got to look out for you too
what happened to booming with Yoko I
just decided I needed a few more
boundaries I mean it's racist man
thanks what he missed you oh I miss him
too wow I'm sorry about Xavier
I'm not he's a liar and a killer
cook them thing may have blabbed about
your date with Tyler so how'd it go
it was interrupted I heard Tyler's
working the late shift
the date shift
come on let's get some Cliffhanger maybe
Katie yes come on then you should lock
your doors
there's some real sick people out there
yeah my dad told me what happened to
Xavier pretty nuts
like I always seems so normal
it has made me reevaluate things
does that mean you're ready to be more
than friends
[Music]
dang and she closed her eyes but it's
definitely not a love drawing she kind
of blinked
oh oh a little smile
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
yes yep yep yep yep yep
[Music]
you okay
you need to go
what
what's wrong
Wednesday's gonna like vomit
of course the first
to be a cycle serial killing
but you don't know if he's a monster on
purpose or not
[Music]
right to the pilgrim World underneath
the pilgrim World sign
well you did it
yeah I know I know you won you beat me
in the prediction game of Wednesday
how's it feel
s good none of the episode matters now
none of the information we need to talk
about anything else nope no prominent
guessing now it's time for a smugness
and gloating now it's time for an
episode eight reaction where we sit
there patting ourselves on the back
Fanning myself the entire time yes it is
a plant shade here please some palm
plant shade
can I get you another Mai Tai sir
um yeah one sec let me just uh clumps
this one little lap oh what uh no that
was an exciting episode it was a very
very exciting episode
with a lot of Thrills
and making sure that a big trailer did
not drop while we're filming this and no
no it hasn't okay we're good uh so yeah
there's
um
there's uh you talk you talk for a while
yeah this is a very thrilling
penultimate episode I mean me like my my
mind goes I know we're basking in the
glory of Victory right now but also I
mean I was I love uh getting a chance to
see Uncle Fester in the action I mean
you know he was not like the the main
point of the episode he doesn't like
take the focus of the episode the way
like The Addams Family coming to visit
does but I was just really pleased and
and excited to have his quirky energy
along for the ride and uh and yeah
helping out with the investigation I can
see that in the future if the show
persists Beyond season two and you know
further down the line every season
having like a Fest drip so to look
forward to love that and uh and yeah
satisfying sort of uh Crest toward the
end of the mystery I was really worried
for thing which you know it's one of
those things where you're like they
can't kill them they're not gonna kill
him but in the moment you're like damn
this feels like they could
well it seems like Tyler doesn't know
that he is it is the height that's how
yeah that's how it seems to be playing
it at least yeah yeah
so there's a chance so I mean so she
definitely wasn't Laurel though I guess
not I mean I feel like she still could
be there could but she would be the
ideas that she would she was controlling
the hide yeah and it doesn't seem as
though that was the case unless they do
bring up that piece of lore about like
whoever
uh you know like if they transform back
or whatever and their true form is
revealed to somebody then that person
like gains the control so maybe they
control like trans what if it's
Christina Richie
you know that makes a lot more sense it
would make a lot of sense and she has
been the benevolent character in plain
sight who we haven't really peeled back
much at all but there was no way she
would be remember this episode the thing
that threw a a hole in that theory for
me and why I had never brought it up was
because
and I didn't know about that until this
episode be oh the other thing that I
thought like wouldn't be working with
Tyler
or an in conjunction with him because of
the scene when Eugene died and we saw
someone go into the cave yeah somebody
both Tyler and Christina Ritchie were at
the dance and they made that really
clear geographically they were both at
the dance when that went down yeah so I
don't know how um because I kept going
like well who wasn't at the dance
could be Tyler's data I suppose
um but I wonder I wonder too because
yeah that is a good point but regardless
I thought this was a fantastic episode
it had a a really great balance of
Whimsy felt very Adam's Family whenever
and it didn't feel like it was tonally
conflicting with the show that we
currently have it managed to keep the
momentum and the pulse uh revved up I
know I'll feed you soon and managed to
keep the pulse and the momentum really
revved up uh while also providing us
that quirky sensibility of Adam's Family
five because you know like the the one
with Morticia and Gomez was a bit more
on that you know emotional Gothic horror
side whereas the the stuff with Uncle
Fester has a little bit more of that
quirky fun Macabre humor so it managed
to blend pretty well I thought with the
current you know uh modern day Wednesday
show that we have here of investigative
Supernatural mysteries of foot and it
was exciting it was exciting time I
really liked Fred armisen's portrayal of
Uncle Fester not like one to go this is
moving up to my childhood or something I
enjoyed what he did I thought I thought
he didn't steal didn't try to steal the
show and I thought him and
um General Ortega had great chemistry
and I loved um seeing Jenna Ortega
become more emotional I love the
challenge I like the idea of when they
choose to reveal that it's Tyler because
this is her most vulnerable episode she
breaks down into tears at the thought of
losing thing
um she admits to missing a friendship
with Enid and and opens up about that
she takes the step to engage in Romance
with Tyler at the end and just when
you've become trusting uh it just
collapses in front of you everything
that you thought you just did right
you'd sell the case you become open and
banned this is why I don't trust people
yeah you know it's uh what's that what's
that word called prophecy something
self-fulfilling prophecy self-fulfilling
prophecy yeah and it's so I think it's a
good like character portrayal of her
maybe it's Christina Ritchie but that
just wouldn't make sense with the cave
scene
yeah
I was trying to yeah I'm trying to do
the Charlie Day yarn mat in my head
because yeah there's been little clues
that she's more than just the good human
teacher nor me teacher there's been a
little clue that she's more and so with
line up and then she comes into town you
know so well in the Laura Gates thing
yeah like I I it would be sort of a big
it would be a Twist of some sort because
of the family's attitude toward uh you
know people at Nevermore than to have
her like infiltrating the place
essentially and you know working from
the inside would be pretty Sinister but
also it makes me wonder what the long
game is of that because it seems like
she's been here a while I can't exactly
remember if they clarify how long Miss
Thornhill has been at the school but you
know it seems as though I don't know
yeah it's good I like being able to go
into the ending episode with you know
still a certain amount of mysteries
especially after all the Tyler stuff
because I feel like that's kind of a
nice tempering is like you have the
Tyler mystery that in some ways you
could argue is one of the easier ones to
figure out
um but they've still managed to have a
certain I don't know man
Tyler that's true that's true not
everybody second episode once you walked
out of that therapy session I was like
definitely yeah that's the one it's a
100 bags yeah
print that one everybody we're going
home yeah yeah no for sure for sure some
you know it was it was a satisfying
mystery in the way they drove it out
wasn't like it was pretty predictable
and then they were trying to make you
not think it's him yes
and then when you're penultimate or your
like Xavier's arrested you're like okay
so it's a hundred percent done yeah yeah
and so I'm wondering too like they I
think they've done a nice job of laying
down Clues and then when Wednesday is
given they do say not to trust the
premonitions they do they do and that's
that's the [ __ ] no you can't you can't
hop off every house right now we got one
more episode
God damn it yeah I mean well and that
makes you wonder like can somebody like
literally from the outside can somebody
affect these Visions in any way is
somebody like planting images in
Wednesday's head you know is there
further framing happening but even so
like I I appreciate the way that they've
smeared some of these details around
because we've kept track of a lot of
things and then yeah having uh Xavier be
framed having everybody's little items
and effects come up uh in that process
like I don't know I'm still I'm still
sitting with a good amount of mystery
I'm like okay principal Weems kind of
dastardly but at the same time I I
always get where she argues she's coming
from so I'm I I I can't fully put it on
her unless she can control more stick
sick more people I'm just like the only
one who wasn't at the dance was the
sheriff
which I feel like it could I don't know
there could be a thing where it's him
and and the guy ducking into the cave
did look like the sheriff to me and I
wonder if that could be a very human
sort of explanation is like maybe he you
know came out of hide form and his dad
caught it and you know
I would think that someone I think
they're missing that there's a third
person in on it I feel like the dad is
in
coordination with this yeah maybe to
protected he's not the one controlling
Tyler yeah he's not the one sicking him
on people he's probably just trying to
like cover up that anybody could ever
find out that Tyler is this way I don't
know and we won't know because we're not
gonna watch the last episode
we were done with the show now we're
gonna leave it here at this Victory
he'll we'll continue it in season two
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah alrighty guys
well
I'm going to bask in the glory for a
while do it do it it was nice good
Legally Blonde moment too so that was a
lovely date I would love to go on a date
like that that was a great date good on
Tyler and spider website where I want to
roll around man that's where I want to
be I want stuff crawling on me terrible
I want to you know get tetanus cutting
myself on something rusty let's go to a
theater you know but that's it that's
that's a normie date while you're going
to the theater paying 1950s films hey
that's how I treat everyone at theaters
hey
look at my popcorn We Love Popcorn I
want to wait till the movie's over
during the movie Yeah clean it up now
because I'm gonna spray my feet out and
I don't want to have anything crunching
underneath it well I watch my movie
alrighty guys well
did you guess it was Tyler I bet most
people did if you didn't guess it was
Tyler comment below and we will be
crying
yes it's pretty obvious it's okay it's
okay we got it though
imagine if you didn't think it was Tyler
yeah it would be an embarrassing
reaction
uh I just I I Justice for Xavier man
Justice for Xavier
um well guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe leave a like leave a
like leave a like and
um hey let's end this with a patron
pandemic Jones hi pandemic Jones
if you were a hide I would love
two to instruct you to go after all
kinds of people
I'm talking blind way yes I'm talking
the norm the normies especially I'm
talking Tyrone Magnus I'd have you take
out all the reactors every single one of
them now
only reaction Channel I'm daunting left
standing it would be the ultimate
pandemic of reactors falling to their
graves yes with only one immune to this
pandemic we would be the vaccine we can
bottle and sell it that's right
I want to keep reacting pay us monthly
because the vaccine only works a month
at a time
you only get immunity to be our patreon
for tier yeah to go to the vaccine yeah
so pandemic I want to thank you because
I know that I wouldn't even need to
control you to do it I would just ask
you kindly and you would go yeah sure
why not I'll go ahead nice guy I'll do
anything for you what kind of hide we
have over here High Tides is what we got
with the pandemic Jones
PJ thank you for being a massive support
and being part of our page for so long
uh you are one of the sexiest rejects we
got sexiest so looking forward to
talking with you more soon I'm assuming
you watched the show I think I've seen
your comments in these videos I've been
avoiding the comments in the last couple
videos because I'm like a little afraid
but uh don't know what's gonna happen to
the end Still Still I haven't got a room
for me I'm very lucky I haven't got
anything over me unfortunately yeah
well done I don't know anything yeah I'm
very lucky
um all right guys we'll talk with y'all
soon thank you PJ
foreign